- [Instructor] In our
journey, studying evolution
and natural selection, we often index on
individual organisms.
If we look at a species or
population of a certain species,
we've talked about how
there could be variation
in that population, which I will depict
by these colors and
these shapes over here.
And sometimes the variation
really doesn't confer
any advantage or disadvantage
for reproduction,
but sometimes it might.
And if a certain variation
maybe because the environment changed
or maybe this population finds themselves
in a new ecosystem confers an advantage,
well, that variant will be
more likely to multiply.
And the genes which produce that phenotype
are more likely to become
a larger and larger
part of the gene pool.
Similarly, if there's some disadvantage,
maybe because the environment
has changed some way,
well, that might select
out certain variants
and the underlying genetics that cause it.
But this is when we're
thinking about traits
that primarily affect an
individual's chances of survival
and reproduction.
But what we're going to do in this video
as this title implies, is focus on...
it's not just about individual traits.
There is also evolution of group behavior,
and we see that right over
here in a school of fish.
Why does it make sense
for these fish to ball up
into this huge school?
It might seem like it makes it very easy
for a predator to just go
right into the middle of that
and open its mouth and
get as much as it wants,
an all you can eat buffet, so to speak.
Well, it turns out that
this type of behavior
does confer a benefit.
The benefit is yes, this
shark that I just drew
might be able to get a mouth full of fish,
but the great majority of the fish
are going to be protected.
And by being in a big ball like this,
instead of just having your own eyes,
looking for a predator,
as soon as any one of
these tens of thousands,
or maybe hundreds of thousands
of fish spot a predator,
well, the whole school will know it.
So they're able to share information.
Also, even though some
fish might get eaten up,
the probability that any one
will be eaten by this shark
is actually lower versus
if there was just one of these fish,
just swimming by itself,
that one is much more
likely to be picked off.
And we see this type of behavior in
many, many, many types of animals.
This right over here is
a herd of wildebeest.
And once again, if you have
an individual wildebeest,
it would be easy to be surrounded by say,
hyenas, by predators, that
could be caught by surprise.
The younger of the wildebeest
would be easy to pick off
if they were by themselves.
But if they're in a herd,
maybe they can be in
the middle of the herd.
Here's an example of adult
elephants protecting their young
when they see a threat approaching.
And notice, more than just the parents
are protecting the young.
These elephants are probably
related to each other.
And so even though one elephant
might sacrifice themselves,
maybe from some type of a threat,
if they're able to protect the young,
even though it might not be their child,
it might be their nephew,
it might be their cousin,
their shared genetics are
more likely to be passed on.
You've sometimes heard
people say things like
I'd be willing to die for two
brothers or eight cousins.
And that would actually make sense
from a genetic point of view,
but it's not just about protection,
where we see the evolution
of group behavior.
We could also see it
in terms of predation.
So this right over here
as a pack of wolves
that are attacking this
bison here, and first of all,
you can see how much more
vulnerable this bison is
when it's alone than if
it were part of a herd.
If it was part of a herd,
it would be much harder to surround it.
You'd have a ton of these
other bison all around
that could run and
chase individual wolves.
But when this bison is
surrounded like this,
when it's outnumbered,
it is more vulnerable.
And these wolves, which are
much, much smaller
individually than this bison
have a decent chance of taking it down.
So once again, this group
behavior of these wolves
to not hunt by themselves,
but to hunt together,
to surround animals, to
coordinate with each other,
that allows them to prey on animals
much, much larger than themselves.
So I encourage you to
think about this idea
because it's happening all around us,
including in human beings.
We are social animals.
This is occurring through
out the animal kingdom.
And it's a really
fascinating thing to observe
all around you.